[Music]
and welcome to this special edition of
Hannity tonight we're holding the media
in this country accountable as I sit
down with the great one Mark Levin for
the entire hour his brand new book on
freedom of the press now we're going to
take a journey that starts at this
nation's founding remembering the once
great press tradition in America and how
it ended up becoming nothing more than a
extension of the Democratic Party in all
things left-wing well uncover what went
wrong how the media fell so far so fast
we'll be exposing every hoax every lie
all their besmirched in this media mob
has told to smear a duly elected
President of the United States and just
do nothing but divide this country from
the Russia collusion delusion to
Covington - ignoring the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal in our
nation's history we're going to take it
apart piece by piece we will expose how
they have abandoned the great tradition
of freedom of the press in this country
choosing to act as nothing but partisan
hacks rather than serious investigators
choosing to put fake news narratives
over facts for years at a time choosing
a smear anyone and everyone who dares
calls out their lack of ethics their
lack of objectivity remember the hate
Trump media mob and the biggest names on
the left never thought it would get to
this point never thought President Trump
would pull off what was one of the
biggest political upsets in American
history and deliver success after
success record after record helping The
Forgotten men and women to this country
let's take a look we better be ready for
the fact that he may be leading the
Republican ticket next I know you don't
which Republican candidate has the best
chance of winning the general election
of the declared ones right now Donald
Trump
[Applause]
mr. Trump to answer your call for
political honesty I just want to say
you're not gonna be President all right
it's been fun
President Obama will go down as perhaps
the worst president in the history of
the United States exclamation point at
real Donald Trump at real Donald Trump
at least I will go down as a president
and a failed one at that I remember how
they reacted the night Donald Trump won
the election November 2016 they started
out they were giddy they were happy the
exit polls well they showed that Donald
Trump didn't win a single state all
through the night the mood started to
change and it became completely unhinged
actually hysteria broke out
you might remember America is crying
tonight I'm not sure how much of America
but a very very significant portion and
I mean literally crying this is a
sadness it is a a mourning moment for
those people and it is it is a moment
filled with fear filled with fear our
country is about to face some serious
crises and so your country needs you
it's a pretty extraordinary thing to say
if you have a son in the Marine Corps
and that you don't trust the
commander-in-chief the people in the
military defend the Constitution this
was a whitewash this was a white lash
against a changing country
it was a white lash against a black
president in part and sadly since that
night things have only gotten worse the
liberal left-wing press they refused to
have any accountability any
responsibility for their failures and
now they're just doubling down on what
is a psychotic anti-trump rage and
frankly destroying whatever credibility
they may have ever had here's just a
small sample of their lowlights
is this president trying to impersonate
Hugo Chavez rest up tie up Irwin
Vladimir Putin he said today America
first it was not just the racial iminium
I should say racial the hit Larry
background to it top needs to be
medicated in hospitalized Donald Trump
again being a schmuck we can truly say
his words have absolutely emboldened
white supremacist he has given oxygen to
racists he is clearly trying to ignite a
civil war in this country there's a sign
out there that's been hung up in the
White House they're outside the way I'll
say if you're not white you're not
especially welcome he's a racist
breathless hysteria conspiracy theories
fake news story after fake news story
every minute every hour every 24-hour
day every week every month as they work
in concert with their partners the
Democratic Party nothing but a mere
extension